If there's one thing that makes me really angry.
*swedish inner hulk*
It just makes my blood just wanna go and...
*Grunt*
I just wanna scream!
*hulk gasm*
it's cheaters
I don't--I don't like em
I don't like em *unknown gibberish* I don't like cheaters
*more hulk gasm*
But no one
dislikes cheaters
As much as Epic games.
I thank you Epic games
For your noble deeds.
You may have heard the story.
"Epic games is suing a 14-year old for cheating in Fortnite, and his mother is fighting back".
Hell yeah.
Epic games.
This is Epic games, and this is haters,
Sue you. I'm gonna sue you.
Suing you left and right
That's great
that there's Epic games is suing this 14 year old and all
but do they know?
Have they confirmed if it's Clara or not?
HAAAA
Wait what the fuck?
Clara!
Hold on
Clara.
Give me one second
Clara!
Let me just message this girl.
Give me one second.
Why the f*ck is this on my computer right now?
Where is this?
How do I close this?
Yo rock I need some help because I don't know what I'm looking at right now
What the f*ck is that?
Hello?
I bet it was Clara.
That son of a sneaky, sneaky snake.
That sneaky snake.
Clara always coming in with her cheats.
Now. If you haven't played Fortnite.
It's a battle royale, uh, type of game
good old fun.
And, uh, people like to cheat in it.
T-E-M-P-Z
Ghost
Yeah, dude.
Yo he just stopped and medded and
literally now there's a fight right in front of him
that he--there's no vision of whatsoever
Yep
instant headshot again
Anoth--And he just shot at somebody that you couldn't even see.
Uh, Yep another one,
another one, yeah, he's a hundred percent
fucking cheating.
Oh my god. I'm fucking recording this shit.
Is that Clara?
that's cl--that's--that's--I think that's Clara
now don't get me wrong I-I-I
Don't understand why you would cheat?
and that's not me making some.
I don't understand how someone could possibly cheat in the game
It's more like
How fun is it to?
Just watch the computer play the game for you, like
you're not playing the game if you're cheating in a first-person shooter
And you're being an asshole,
okay, you're being an ass so stop cheating.
That's right.
Family fr--
nice guy PewDiePie
telling you here, right as it is now
don't cheat in video games.
Cheating is a huge problem for
fortnite and, uh
So what does epic games the creator of fortnite do?
they make a statement.
They made a statement on their website saying that they're gonna strike down on these cheaters.
They're gonna. They're gonna
They're gonna get them. They didn't say how though
They said
"We don't want to give too many clues about what we're doing
but we're going to roll out tools"
epic games just going like
Hehehe
ehhh, we're not--we're not gonna give too many clues,
how we're gonna stop these cheaters
but, ahhh, we got--we have some ideas
about a week later,
it comes out that Epic sues Fortnight cheaters for
copyright infringement
It seems a bit weird to sue someone
cheating for copyright infringement
like that's how they strike down on them
But apparently I might be wrong
I don't really understand the whole coding bit,
but they're (the cheaters) changing
the coding
Which they don't own the copyright to
and they're not allowed to do that
so that's copyright infringement
I don't...I don't
how do you mod then?
what's--what's modding then? is modding illegal?
Uh, in their legal document though, they
They wrote, "cheats give a cheater power to do or see things that other players cannot
for instance a cheat might enable a cheater
to see through solid objects,
teleport,
or make moves other players cannot,
such as a spin
followed by
an instant headshot to another player".
I'd never thought
I'd see a 360 no-scope being described in legal terms
well done, Epic games
Literally any online game will lose players
if it gets infested by cheaters
It's statistically proven every time that cheaters drive players away
and for good reasons
No one likes to play with the cheater
It's--it's not fun
their approach to this was to
sue these players
to stop people from cheating
people are saying they're making an example out of these people
both defendants face up to
$150,000 statutory damages
for copyright infringement
Now I've seen arguments on both side of this saying
This is ridiculous
Even by game publisher standards
ban the offenders and move on
if your game is easily broken
it's on you
but then I have the other side of people saying
Good. You know, we don't like cheaters.
They're ruining the game
I'm glad they are striking down on them.
It's a very
Divided topic
and that's what we discuss here on the PewDiePie channel
the thing though that this comment, eh
Isn't taken into account
is that Fortnite is a free-to-play game
You can't just ban the player
They're just gonna make a new an account
and that's what was happening with one of the cheaters
is that they made new accounts over
and over and over and
That's why they finally decided okay.
We need to stop these guys
Now then it came out
through a document sent by the mother of one of the cheaters
that he is
14 year old
there was a plea sent to the jer- uh- judge from the mother who...
People speculate as a lawyer,
and she makes a pretty good case against Epic Games actually
she basically states that Fortnite needs
a legal parents consent for minors
And that she never gave this consent
epic games also claimed that they lost
profit because of cheaters
and that they are to blame for that
But she's saying there's no way you can actually prove that
She says that it's wrong for them to go against the players
instead of the websites
distributing the cheats
and she's also pointing out that her son's name
publicly was mad--was made public
and that's against Delaware laws,
so she makes a pretty good point.
Atatatata
so you might think okay
Well Epic Games, you know they overreacted they--
$150,000 that's just stupid. Okay.
It's a fourteen-year-old kid,
but you go to the...
The fourteen-year-old's channel
And it has quality-quality content
such as "GTA V MOD TROLLING (FT RAPIST)"
Quality
just the finest
there's him
cheating in GTA 5
I pressed y and I flew out of the car and smoothed across the ground
into the bush
alright, alright, say whatever you want
he's not even back
Alright. Yeah. We officially proved that you're the hacker man
How to mod COD BlackOps on Xbox.
storage and then a hover over--
All right now once you booted up the...you guys wanna click on the new authors
And he also made a response video
to the lawsuit which is
It's hard to empathize with the guy.
Yo, what's going on guys, Sky Orbit here
in this video guys
This isn't a modding video, so this is just gonna be talking about my a lawsuit with epic games,
so yeah, uh,
Let's get started
alright
So what happened was I was basically cheating and uh...
The game Fortnite, and I'm pretty sure all of you know this
really good that he just admitted it
Well done!
You know I downloaded a sheet from the internet
unknown cheats taught me--
He promotes the cheating website... *inner facepalm*
fucking hell, this guy's an idiot
Well Fortnite cheats are fucking everywhere
you can get them from any place, anytime, anywhere
now in this lawsuit, Epic games is basically
Saying that I coded a cheat
and I was selling it and
I admitted to me making the cheat
Which I never made that cheat
I never coded the cheat
I never sold the cheat
It was free to public.
you could actually get it on unknowncheats.me
If you guys know that website is
it's basically just downloading hacks.
It's a free hack
You can get it from anywhere.
So basically he was streaming himself cheating
showing that he was cheating
telling players
Where to download the cheat and how they can cheat as well.
Pretty scumbag thing to do
Epic's response to this was basically
"Epic is not okay with ongoing cheating or copyright infringement from anyone at any age."
I don't really understand
How its copyright infringement eh...
Feel free to educate me on that
there was another legal document filed
From Epic Games where they quote the cheaters saying uh...
"New (Now) method is exposed
Epic Eat my ass."
Defendant posted in...
Defendant posted his
Circumvention method to the cheat providers discussion channel
so that other cheaters could use it
and bragged "Now method is exposed."
"Epic eat my ass."
Also one of the other cheaters is
a moderator and member of...
addictedcheats.net
so it doesn't look great for the kid
it really doesn't
I don't think he deserves it
When..eh...I think when you're 14
you do a lot of dumb shit and
downloading a cheat
and having your parents having to pay $150,000
that doesn't really seem fair to me
Even if you want to set an example...
I cheated when I was a kid at games
I cheated in tibia where basically the game would play itself
But that felt like I'm--
I'm cheating the the game
not other players
you could argue that it was
but it's different to me in a first-person game
Cuz you're ruining the game for cheating it.
I don't understand why you would
but kids like to do it
uh, but I can't say that I don't understand, why kids don't do it
kids are stupid
I think epic is uh- doing the right thing
to strike down on cheaters.
I absolutely do
but at the same time
I don't think this is gonna stop cheaters.
Strike down on the websites distributing the cheats
focus on having counter measurement
to the cheats.
I'm sure they've already working on that
But...
They own the engine
it shouldn't be impossible
to figure some system out.
There's always gonna be cheaters
But
this just seems like a whole mess to me
And the kind of case where just everyone loses
The kids parents are gonna lose money and time and effort
and epic games are gonna lose some of their PR
at the end of the day
no one likes a cheater.
I don't like cheaters either
Don't cheat
because cheating is bad
You heard it here first
What do you think?
Leave a comment down below.
Who is right?
Epic Games?
14 year old kid?
Let me know in the comments
and as always...
Don't cheat because your...
No
Just don't do it
Leave a like. *thumbs up*